well it's time to check in with the
bosses here at reason it's our reason
round up with editor-in-chief of Reason
magazine Matt Welch hi Matt hi and of
course the editor-in-chief of reason
calm and reason TV Nikolas B thanks
we've also got our paperback version of
our book the Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America coming out now you
know who needs to read that New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg yeah sure
what's going on with the soda ban he's
banned soda beverages sugary drinks over
16 ounces first of all what's to stop
someone from buying two of them and
second of all what is the scientific
link between sugary drinks and obesity
there has to be a direct one according
to his health commissioner up to half of
all obesity related problems are
attributed to sugary sodas in New York
City with it's not scientific at all I
mean the it starts where they call it an
obesity epidemic and that's not an
epidemic you can't catch it by breathing
on someone or doing anything like that
so yeah people are drinking sugar eating
bad food and becoming fat the question
is does the government's have any role
or right to say that because of that you
can no longer have a 20 ounce bottle of
coke period they're trying to legislate
criminalize actual people's choices and
it's not just people it's generally
those people it's lower-class people who
drink those others why not just out
Long's great soda I mean that's
essentially what he's doing okay now
this is my solution before before you
get into it hot stuff
why don't you disincentivize obesity by
not offering free health care yeah well
I mean this is the problem the health
people the you know nanny state public
health people will say well you know
this is what happens to the externality
of being fat is that everybody pays for
it the easiest answer to that is to
change the way health care is delivered
so that fat people or you know and it's
like you know being overweight does not
necessarily mean you have health
problems yeah yeah I might be morbidly
obese by the government
but you know the whole point is is that
the externality is only there because of
the way we deliver healthcare and if
people actually paid for themselves
primarily this wouldn't be an issue but
you know as Matt was saying there is
something funky going on here you know
so for instance among the things that
are exempted are alcoholic beverages so
you can get a 20 ounce margarita you
just can't get a 20 ounce lime Slurpee
and in the same week that Bloomberg was
pushing this idea he also celebrated
national donut day with the world's
largest box of intamin doughnuts and
there were intimate doughnuts that were
the size of manhole covers and that's
okay but you know the god forbid that
you get that 17,000 would have to
increase the circumference of the
manhole covers because New Yorkers are
now too obese to fit down them so so
Scott Walker the recall election in
Wisconsin it gives me the heebie-jeebies
having lived through the great Davis
recall and I saw what happened in
California it was exciting it seemed
revolutionary we have huge pension
problems in that state Scott Walker
survived but what does it do for the
rest of the country well I think it
hopefully focuses them in the fact that
they have the same problems every state
and especially but not only blue states
and blue cities counties they all have
the problems of chronically underfunded
and over-expansion expensive public
pension liabilities we've been just
giving better and better contracts to
state workers who already make much more
money on average for the same work or
the same category of work as people in
the private sector it's not just Scott
Walker it's not just Wisconsin it's
everywhere it's California and New York
and so people gonna have to deal with
this without being able to demonize a
single politician now I know unions
don't want you to demonize unions but
they essentially trade votes for richer
pensions think about it in the state of
California the largest two or three
groups that contribute to elections are
public sector union groups basically
teachers unions and state employees
unions so they get politicians elected
Democrats elected and then they go to
the negotiating table with those same
people they help get elected and write
the new pension rules oftentimes in
closed sessions not even open
like so a lot of the worst deals we've
done completely behind closed doors like
in 1999 your parent boyfriend great
Davises was terrible about this actually
right and then but he was recalled for a
reason I mean he allowed the budget to
be exploded partially by giving
sweetheart deals to the pension or the
labor groups that supported him so
floating the prison workers to prison
workers I mean in Scott Walker in one of
the bad things that he did is that he
didn't go after fire and police because
those are traditionally Republican
unions as opposed to democratic unions
everyone has to deal with this San Jose
pays 27 percent of its budget just on
pension contributions right now that's
completely off the rails on sustain you
know something like 60% of Wisconsin
residents thought that firemen and cops
should also pay more for their benefit
so you know the yet the I mean the the
consensus is building that you know you
we can't have business as usual in state
you know state finances happening and
the other thing about the California
recall is you know Gary Coleman was on
the ballot and he was he was running for
smaller government he embodied smaller
government that was an opportunity we
missed here is a moment of hypocrisy the
New York Times said essentially that
Barack Obama was just exaggerating in
his book when he talked about his drug
use but now it turns out according to
David Maraniss his biography him really
was a big puff puff pass er he was in
the Chum gang Jim guy yeah Schumi gang
which is much better sounding gang than
I was involved with at the time
yes spur posse no I it shows up
something that that is a real blot on
his record and hopefully will actually
lead to him losing some support
particularly among young people it's
complete hypocrisy Barack Obama
basically is advocating and enforcing
laws that if they would have been
enforced on him as a young person he
would have gone to jail right would that
have made him a better person but that
have made his life turn around
differently hell no it's just partly
wouldn't have gotten into Harvard Law
School that's true it's you know this is
also a place where politicians
we bemoan they fade or rather that you
know the way that the media and other
people create cynicism among the body
populace or you know the body politic
and it's time that people like President
Obama recognize his behavior here and
the hypocrisy
it really is egregious and it turns
people off and if politicians are
sinking lower than kind of you know Penn
State assistant football coaches in
terms of admiration it's because of
stuff like this I mean pure and simple
it's on that it is on that Jerry
Sandusky polls better in 67 percent of
the country than Nancy Pelosi I wouldn't
the true story that's not a reason route
poll yeah but it is equally scientific
all right there we have it you can read
Reason magazine with its editor-in-chief
Matt Welch you can always go to reason
calm and reasoned on TV that editor in
chief Nicholas be a girl and a girl
thank you both
you